these days you can learn practically
anything from the internet
so the concept of being an apprentice
craftsman may seem a little old school
but here in the countryside of kochi
japan there is a small blacksmith
workshop where the apprenticeship style
of learning has not completely
disappeared
[Laughter]
these blades are called natta and they
are used by professional wood cutters
here in cochi which is a heavily
forested region of the country they are
the tool chiefly made by this master
craftsman
[Music]
[Music]
but three years ago after nearly a
lifetime of working alone matsumura was
joined by a young man
[Music]
when he learned about matsumura kikuchi
left his manufacturing job in the city
and approached the aging master who was
hesitant to take on the young man as an
apprentice
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and for kikuchi it's not only about
learning from his master but learning
how to think like his master
internet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
you